a lot of folks think that a librarian is
just some of your checks books in and
out of a library for you but that's not
true librarian is a highly skilled
profession that requires a lot of
specialized training it's about helping
people research and access knowledge in
whatever way makes sense through the
20th century that knowledge was held in
books and on microfilm tapes stored in
central buildings in each town like this
one as a public good which is actually
almost miraculous when you think about
it the modern public library is a
revolutionary wonderful idea knowledge
and information should be available to
everyone not just the rich and not just
the clever in the 21st century that's
still true a lot of that information
might be online now and available to our
phones but in-depth research searching
out truth from fiction shouldn't be just
for people who are able to understand
complex academic citations and
referencing if you don't know how to
look something up if you don't even know
really what you're looking for if you
don't have the words the librarians job
is to help you find out in an ideal
world that's what librarians would be
doing not pushing a cart and moving
books around by hand that's why here at
OU d the new helsinki central library
those books are being moved by a robot
this order building was built last year
so it's pretty new building and that's
why we have a lot of new technology and
new services in here it has been said
that it's like living room for citizens
so for example in the first floor we
have movie theater then in the second
row we have things to do for example 3d
printers and laser cutters and music
studios and even a kitchen you can play
computer games we have beer classes
there and gaming computers or isn't that
traditional library so in third floor
where we have our books it's not that
silent space people can talk there
freely and so we have few classrooms for
silent reading in normal like big
libraries there's usually some kind of
returning machine that sorts the books
the right places
we have also that here customers can
return books from first floor and they
will come
using the conveyer to this basement and
they will be sorted by January and
language that's pretty basic stuff but
we are in progress of further automating
it so we have a couple of robotic arms
and then we have three mobile robots
those mobile robots will pick up these
boxes and they will be transferred by
them to the third floor where staff can
shelf the books small part of books will
be shelved by our robotic arm that I
will put the books in shelves and when
the Shelf is full it will be transferred
by those mobile robots then we have some
plans to use mobile robots in knights to
scan the books with arif ID antenna so
we know if there's any books in wrong
places those mobile robots that we are
using our plans so that they can avoid
collisions with people if someone gets
in front of a robot it will calculate
new route and find another way to get to
the right position at least at this
point there hasn't been any accidents or
things like that so robots and humans
have been getting together very well and
people are quite curious about them and
why we have them here and what they can
do this library gets a lot of press for
its robots there was even a design
prototype with googly eyes that guided
people to the shelf they wanted but most
people can read a map or follow
directions the real job of the robots
here is the same as robots everywhere
Automation don't waste the librarians
time with tasks that a computer can now
do if you think public libraries are
just about collections of books and yeah
of course they seem outdated public
libraries in the 21st century can be
where you go to borrow a book that's not
going to stop
but libraries were never just about
books they're about information free at
the point of use no price tag they're
about collaboration and communication
and about making sure that everyone can
find truth most libraries don't have
robots but every library does have
librarians and there what's important
thanks so much to all the team at Aldi
for showing me around find out more
about them
by clicking the link in the description
[Music]